[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
April 17th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
Millennials have faced economic
challenges since many of them began
their careers during the 2008 financial
crisis but now the group born between
1980 and the early 2000s is falling
deeper into debt at a faster rate than
any other segment we'll talk to a 31
year old mother of two struggling to
make ends meet in a moment but first wsj
reporter Gina Heap joins us Gina thanks
very much for being with us thanks so
much for having me so Gina a lot of
people across age groups have racked up
debt as we've emerged from the pandemic
but how bad has it gotten for
Millennials so Americans in their 30s
have taken on debt at a really
remarkable Pace since the pandemic their
total balances Rose to more than 3.8
trillion in the fourth quarter which is
a 27 jump from three years ago before
the pandemic it's also the fastest pace
of debt accumulation over a three-year
period since the FED started this survey
in 1999 that's excluding the financial
crisis of course in which a housing
bubble drove those numbers to something
like 40 percent but still that's an
enormous ramp up right it's a pretty
stunning Trend we're seeing so how does
their debt profile compare to other age
groups the rate at which Americans in
their 30s are taking on debt is higher
than any other generation for example
the average credit card balance for
Millennials Rose to about six thousand
seven hundred fifty dollars in January a
26 rise from 2019 levels balances didn't
really change for Gen X and for older
Generations they actually fell between
11 and 15 percent so you can see it's a
pretty stark contrast how did
Millennials get themselves into this
really tough debt situation so what we
saw over the pandemic is that households
in general did Better Than People
expected in 2020 they were stuck at home
because of lockdown they were receiving
stimulus payments and they were able to
pay down some debt but those benefits
are over the economies reopened and
people are back to traveling and
commuting and those stimulus payments
have ended and they've ended at a kind
of a tough moment for the economy
inflation pressuring people's budgets
and the last round of stimulus checks
went out in 2021 and Millennials are
getting hit the hardest in some ways
many spent thousands of dollars on
unplanned child care costs when schools
were closed and some relied heavily on a
pandemic era child tax credit program
that stopped and a lot are trying to buy
homes
Stacy Copeland is among Millennials
facing this uphill battle she's 31 has
two children and lives just outside of
Miami she was saving money to buy a home
before the pandemic Stacy thank you very
much for being with us thank you for
having me so Stacy what do your personal
finances and your debt in particular
look like now compared to say the start
of the pandemic before the pandemic I
didn't really have any debt and I had
less credit cards
and then from the start of the pandemic
and then
to now I've gotten like three more
credit cards and now they're all pretty
much maxed out I have been able to
tackle two of them this year and get
done totally at a zero balance which is
great it just takes a lot of dedication
you just gotta live off of nothing just
get it done so how are things going now
how are you trying to manage your debt
and do you see some sort of path to
relief from that debt right now I've cut
out eating out I don't go out anymore
I've don't buy anything that I don't
need I live like I have absolutely
nothing like I can go and spend money if
I really wanted to but that extra money
that I don't need to be spending I'm
just putting it throwing it at the debt
like did The Snowball Effect with my
credit cards so I paid the lowest amount
got that done once the second one and
just kept going I'm keeping that
transition and going that way huh sounds
like a series of small battles yeah you
feel good and then your determination
gets even more and more because you
actually see progress and you're doing
it so it's good how is this increase in
debt change the way you spent before the
pandemic both my kids were in sports my
daughter did swimming for a while and
they both did flag football and my son
is always an Aftercare program at school
and even before the pandemic it was
about 170 a month and now after it is I
pay a little over 200 a month so you can
see how much it really has changed
before the pandemic things were a lot
cheaper you go to store and you have a
full card and you know be like a little
under a hundred dollars now forget it
after the pandemic it's close to 200 300
just for two shampoos I took my daughter
she got two shampoos and a body wash and
a deodorant and I spent forty dollars
and it's just basic stuff nothing crazy
it's crazy all right that's Miami area
resident Stacy Copeland Stacy thank you
very much for being with us thank you
for having me I really appreciate it
so Gina let's look long term here what
does this debt picture look like for
Millennials going forward so there was
already a really significant and growing
wealth gap between Millennials and other
Generations before the pandemic and this
rapid build up that we've seen the past
few years could actually worsen that
Trend it's really important for people
of prime working age to feel like
they're on Good Financial footing
because it empowers them to take risks
that can empower the broader economy so
that includes things like starting a new
business or investing but for
Millennials in their 30s they haven't
been feeling that way they weren't
before the pandemic and they certainly
aren't now we know that this group has
much lower rates of home ownership than
other generations and that's the main
way that we build wealth in this country
and a lot of Millennials feel like
that's Out Of Reach for them like we saw
with Stacy the housing boom that we saw
over the pandemic really drove up prices
as well as mortgage rates and it's made
monthly payments unaffordable for a lot
of people in this group so this current
experience they're going through can
have a lasting effect exactly all right
that's Wall Street Journal reporter Gina
with us Gina thank you very much
for being with us on the show thanks so
much for having me Jr and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]